foreign
January the 8th 2008
[Music]
it was approximately 6 p.m in the
afternoon
then the sun was just going down
and my buddy Mike Odom called me and
says you want to come over and enjoy the
afternoon we'll be able to camp fire up
on the hill and just hang out and shoot
the breeze and I said sure can
second I got out of my pickup
I noticed some lights coming at us at a
very high rate of speed
I asked Mike and Lance if they were
seeing what I was seeing
they replied back yes we're seeing it
we saw craft coming from the East going
west
had extremely large lights like a
magnesium flare
almost burnt your eyes to look at it
and it was moving extremely fast faster
than any normal aircraft that we have
around here
and as we watched it we saw that it had
two F-16 jets in Hot Pursuit after it
chasing it
I know what a F-16 is I'll go to air
shows and pretty familiar with aircraft
it was unbelievable it left us all in
shock
you know it was a
out of this world
last week several people in Stephenville
Texas witnessed what many are calling a
UFO the Air Forces lied about UFOs for
60 years actually and this would be in
keeping with that in the late 40s and
early 50s there was so many sightings
across the United States it was in the
middle of Cold War so government
officials were trying to figure out what
these objects were the government
examined over 12
000 UFO sightings many of those wore a
striking resemblance to what we're
seeing today there have been a certain
percentage of reports by credible
observers of relatively incredible
things
the Air Force I think for a time may
have been making an honest effort to
clear the air about the phenomena
unfortunately it didn't last too long to
this time there is no valid scientific
proof that we have been visited by
spaceships they were inundated by these
reports and just wanted to be done with
the whole thing we are not hiding
anything we have nothing to hide this
became the launch of taboo on a more
official level
ridicule became sanctioned I would like
to have answers but I'm not sure if
we'll ever get any
we get reports every night I don't know
what the hell it is wrong
in 2017 two colleagues and I published a
story in the New York Times about a
Secret Pentagon program studying UFOs
the story was on the front page of the
New York Times and it was huge it was
covered everywhere all over the world it
was like such a sea change for me as a
journalist and also for the issue of
UFOs in general
for most people this was the first time
they heard anything about any official
relationship between the government and
UFOs
[Music]
but actually in the late 1940s the
government was really starting to wake
up to what this issue was really all
about
it's extremely important to understand
that the Cold War affected both the
perception of UFOs and how it was
handled by the military
it's hard for us today to remember what
the mindset was but it was Dire it was
life and death between the United States
and Soviet Union there was people out
with binoculars all over the country
constantly searching the skies for a
Russian strike
it was only natural that during the Cold
War UFOs sort of got folded into this
overriding fear of what might attack us
at any given time
and then in 1947 just when these Cold
War fears were starting to take hold
there was a very famous sighting by a
pilot named Kenneth Arnold that was the
sighting that marked the beginning of
the modern era of UFOs
it all began with an incident which
occurred in 1947. on the afternoon of
June 24th of that Year Kenneth Arnold
made the first report on flying saucers
Kenneth Arnold was a Private Pilot
searching for a military plane that had
crashed sometime earlier and he sees off
in the distance a chain of nine silvery
objects he said they look sort of like
silver pie plates with a crescent cut
out of them many times they went going
over a thousand miles an hour
nothing in 1947 was capable of traveling
1200 miles an hour nor did we have any
aircraft that looked like this they seem
to flip and Flash in the sun just
[Music]
yes he landed at his next stop at the
next airport and told the flight crew
what he had encountered and people
pretty much just laughed him off but
when he got to his next stop there were
reporters waiting for him
he described their movement as a saucer
skipping across the water and that
reporter thought ah flying saucers
that's what we'll call them
and that's what we've been using ever
since
in the aftermath of Kenneth Arnold's
report there were hundreds and hundreds
of reports pouring into the air force
every day and the Air Force couldn't
just ignore that
it was in the middle of Cold War so
government officials were trying to
figure out what these objects were
General Twining saw this phenomenon as a
possible threat
to our country so he issued a very
famous memo in which he said
the phenomenon reported is something
real
not Visionary or fictitious
those were pretty big words coming from
a general in the Air Force in the summer
of 1947.
the Twining memo marked the beginning of
an era in which the Air Force would
become deeply involved with the question
of UFOs
the government was put in a position
where it had to decide was it going to
engage with this phenomenon and if so
how much of it was it going to make
public that continued on in the decades
that followed and it impacted all the
cases that came decades later
the Stephenville Texas UFO case is very
intriguing to me
in 2008 a large unidentified flying
object was observed by a large number of
people from the ground when we first saw
it it had seven lights across the back
of it all blinking in no particular
order
as it approached Stephenville these
seven lights became a heart shape of
seven lights and then a brief moment
later they burst into a flame and it
looked to me like the flame was
contained in a rectangle box
somebody had made the comment well is it
half the size of a Walmart
says much bigger than the normal wall
bar
what made the Stephenville case so
interesting was that in a four hour
period of time you had dozens of reports
of an object and they all described
saying the same thing
it happened about 12 and a half 13 years
ago
I still think about it quite often
we're still trying to find out and
discover what the cause of it was
it just had two large bright intense red
lights with a white light in the center
of it and it had two military jets
behind it which everybody saw in town
the Jets they was running Full Throttle
but they wasn't able to catch it there
were fighter jets chasing those lights
and the Jets couldn't keep up with them
and then it just left it was gone that
fast
what do you think it was
I don't know what it was but I know what
an airplane
after that I spoke to probably two or
three hundred people that witnessed it
business owners city councilman
policeman
but no one could say what we saw that
night
I called a Stephenville Empire Tribune
to see if anybody may have got a visual
on it the editor directed me to a
newspaper reporter named Angela Joyner
She interviewed me over the phone and
she started digging deep to help find
out what we were seeing
she was hell-bent to find out the truth
[Music]
my name is Sarah Vandenberg and I was
the managing editor of the Stephenville
Empire Tribune for 14 years
in 2008 Steve Allen and a couple of his
friends saw some suspicious lights and
they called in to The Newsroom and
talked to Angela Joyner
Angela Joyner is one of my reporters at
the Empire Tribune sadly Angela passed
away with covid last year
Angela was a super fun person but she
took her seriously
good writer she was thorough she was a
good reporter
Steve Allen called me and said hey I got
a story for you and I could tell by
talking to him you know the way his
voice changed and his inflections
changed and and he was just so sincere
when he was describing it to me
I knew this guy saw something he really
saw something big
after Steve Allen called she pitched the
story to me and said here's what's
happened what do you think did you
did you win a reporting on this yeah it
just seems like you know it's the
thought of the little green men coming
out of the spaceship it was sort of
tabloid-ish to me
that was my concern as a journalist who
wanted to be taken seriously I was
afraid that you know this would somehow
taint my reputation so I said put
something together and Pitch it to me
tomorrow evening when I get back to the
office and then we'll talk about it
this siding was like right here in our
core readership area and I thought you
know the readers are going to like this
they're going to really like this so and
the people they they know the people in
the story that's another thing so that
was another reason I went ahead and did
it
to uh and the editor left early
cut that part
[Laughter]
next morning at the end of my driveway
was the paper I picked it up and across
the top had UFO sightings in Erath
County and like 72 Point font it was
just huge after I had left for the day
the publisher and Angela we did the
front page and went to press and I had
no idea I almost had a nervous breakdown
right then I could not believe that that
had happened overnight
two hours into my day I got a call from
the publisher she said things are
blowing up we've sold out of all the
papers we've had that was my first
indication like wow people are really
interested in this
did a lot of excitement here a lot of
businesses had t-shirts made and sold
those and the high school kids had fun
with it Stephenville may be typical but
what's happening in the sky is above it
is a whole other story it kind of is the
Talk of the Town right now Angela Joyner
is a reporter with the town's newspaper
she's now on the strangest and possibly
the biggest story of her life
it went from this little story to this
huge out of control worldwide Frenzy
I started getting phone calls from all
over the world Brazil Japan England
and next thing you know CNN and quite a
few other TV things showed up and
pointed our story
similar to that is that despite the
numbers of witnesses seeing these
gigantic craft nobody in positions of
authority came to investigate
that's in contrast to what was going on
in the 40s and 50s where there was an
Air Force program and they would
investigate cases
here is a picture that was released just
today it shows four luminous objects in
formation in the sky over Salem
Massachusetts
now here on this map are pinpointed
locations where some 30 saucers have
been cited and are still unexplained
in 1949
the military started looking into all
these stacks of UFO reports that the Air
Force was receiving
headquarters United States Air Forces
issued a directive for a detailed study
of flying disc reports
the program is initially called project
sign
then became project Grudge
and then it was named Project Blue Book
Project Blue Book was operated out of
the dingiest office at Wright-Patterson
Air Force Base
they had a malfunctioning coffee pot
they had a couple desks they had a big
map up on the wall and that was it but
they just had a system down
Project Blue Book started as a good
faith effort by the government to
collect reports and investigate UFOs
when there were big cases they would
sometimes dispatch someone to interview
the witnesses
the Air Force was pretty open about
Project Blue Book
what are the objectives
first of all to try to determinate some
useful phenomenally against the threat
to the security of the United States
from second to determining for youthful
phenomena exhibit any technological
advantage
alongside the military employees the Air
Force felt that they needed a credible
scientific opinion to support their
research is it in the realm of
possibility that there are spaceships
someplace in this universe
well if you put it in the word use the
word possibility and not probability
then I would have to say I think is any
scientists would have to say it is
certainly possible yes
jln heineck was a mild mannered college
professor from Ohio State University his
job was to go through all these stacks
of UFO reports that the Air Force was
receiving and try to find out what's
going on
Project Blue Book examined over 12
000 UFO sightings many of them bore a
striking resemblance to what we're
seeing today
crafts with a similar shape sometimes
the same color
hovering then shooting off
instantaneously at Hypersonic speeds
multiple multiple cases like that
while working for Project Blue Book
heineck noticed that he was able to
explain 80 percent of cases but he also
noticed that there was about a 20
residue of cases that he hadn't been
able to explain away
Alan Haida came into the UFO project
with the attitude which is there's
nothing to UFOs
but he was a good enough scientist to
say wait a minute I'm seeing reports
here that are not easily explainable
the Air Force and their UFO study
project may have been making an honest
effort to clear the air about the
phenomenon unfortunately it didn't last
too long
simply because they were just
overwhelmed with reports
[Music]
and it turned a blue green bring up
light walls were ahead of us and all of
a sudden they Zapped away from us
this is the Kremlin Russia Today is
regarded as a grave threat to our nation
to our freedom to the Peace of the world
40s and 50s tensions with Russia were
building
Cold War was so intense at that point so
there was a genuine concern that the UFO
phenomenon could be exploited
the U.S government felt adversaries
could hoax UFO sightings and then clog
up our reporting channels and then have
a surprise attack so the idea was that
the UFO problem was not a security
problem as such meaning aliens aren't
going to land and attack us what the UFO
problem was it was a sociological
problem
and it was one that demanded a different
approach
[Music]
the CIA Under the Picture by convening a
panel of top scientists to examine the
UFO phenomenon the thinking was that the
enemy couldn't exploit UFOs as a decoy
in the preparation for an attack on the
United States
five outstanding scientists in various
Air Force and CIA Representatives would
immediate among the panel members was J
Allen the heineck
in 1953 the Central Intelligence Agency
formed a scientific panel led by a
highly regarded scientist named
Robertson to examine this phenomenon its
implications the Robertson panel was a
group of hand-picked scientists who came
together to try to determine a way to
damp down public interest in UFOs Dr
heineck was actually brought in to be a
Consulting witness to the Robertson
panel the panel members were seated
around this table
it was a rather somber and impressive
occasion actually
the mission given by the Robertson panel
was essentially to make people stop
filing UFO reports
they proposed two methods to damp down
public enthusiasm one was through
debunking
the second one was through education
teaching people to explain UFOs in other
ways than something extraordinary
it was an extremely important moment in
the evolution of how government was
going to engage with this topic this
became the launch of taboo on a more
official level where it was becoming
policy in a way
ridicule became a sanctioned
the Robertson panel conclusions seemed
to have a big impact on Project Blue
Book the project began to dismiss as
many cases as possible and provide
sometimes ridiculous explanations for
them just have an answer and make them
go away
heineck's job became going through all
these UFO reports and explained them
away as natural occurrences Comet meteor
shooting star Sundog Eclipse I would say
the great majority are balloons meteors
satellites aircraft seen with the sun
glinting off of them generally quite
usual things seen under unusual
circumstances or surprising
circumstances Dr Ryan did his job very
thoroughly Allen was was a fellow trying
to please the Air Force in what they
wanted
would have a bunch of reports dropped on
his desk and he would explain them all
away if a report said probable airliner
they would cross out probable and just
say airliner that's what the witness saw
it was kind of an insult to the to the
to the intelligence of the American
people
heineck they've taken the job for the
extra money struggling young
professional with a growing family of
course he's not going to turn down work
but behind the scenes heineck gradually
realized that this was a scientific
problem but he wouldn't go out and state
it publicly he didn't want to do that
because it would have been what the Air
Force didn't want him to do
even though it took place in 1953 the
Robertson panel was so potent in terms
of its desire to clamp down to ridicule
to debunk and to quotes educate people
to interpret UFOs in other ways its
Legacy carried on through the decades
and it impacted cases like Stephenville
and other cases of the time
last week several people in Stephenville
Texas a small rural town of about
fifteen thousand witnessed what many are
calling a UFO in Selden Texas as Steve
Allen also there is Angela Joyner staff
writer for the Empire Tribune the local
newspaper in Stephenville Angela what
are some witnesses telling you the thing
that I hear over and over and over is
how bright the lights were so I think
there's been a lot of consistency in the
spottings
it was Angela that started digging deep
she was hell-bent on try to find out
what we saw and what happened
and it almost consumed her
the incredible thing about the
Stephenville sightings was that
Witnesses reported see F-16 Fighters
pursuing this object I heard this really
really loud noise and I ran out the
front door and there were fighter jets
chasing those lights
Angela wanted to know what the Air Force
knew about the two f-16s than what we
saw so she got in touch with the Naval
Air Station in Fort Worth and talked to
the major Carl Lewis
major Carl Lewis said we didn't have any
aircraft in your area at that time
I feel like we wasn't given the truth in
the military it didn't seem like they
was interested in any questions
then on about the 10th day the military
issued a press release
now in a plot line that's out of the
X-Files Air Force officials are saying
they concede they had f-16s over
Stephenville Texas on the evening of
January 8th
major Carl Lewis says there was an
internal Communications mistake
the plot thickened
Litton Air Force wouldn't say why they
did in fact have f-16s in the area
Angela joyneth says that the Air Force's
admission that it did indeed have
fighter jets as reported by the
witnesses bolsters their story all
around military coming out with this at
this point just as is going to fuel the
fire for okay there is something going
on now what is it
we thought their attempt to try to
explain it away it was terribly strange
we had more questions than answers
[Music]
UFO reports hoax or serious sightings
wind up here at Wright-Patterson
Airfield in Dayton Ohio the Air Force
investigative unit is known as Project
Blue Book
in the wake of the Robertson panel
Project Blue Book was investigating
these civilian reports as a way to Tamp
down public concern
for example in Michigan there were at
one point a large number of sightings by
people in a community there and Walter
Cronkite the Arbiter of Truth for many
Americans covered the story great Flying
Saucer mystery of 1966 began here
near Dexter Michigan late in March as I
turned around to come back on the porch
I looked to the north of me and looked
like a fallen star who beat her it was
red kind of coming down and break my
nerves UFO remained over his swamp more
than four hours
40 miles away another swamp land and
another UFO sighting I believe that I
can't fathom it because it seems so
unreal
this was a huge National story everyone
was demanding that Blue Book
solved the case
and so they called in heinek his Air
Force Project Blue Book boss said get
out there and put a lid on this
the Air Force said its Chief scientific
consultant on UFOs Professor Jay Allen
heineck to check the Michigan sightings
illusion of motion frequently is given
by the fact that a little bit of swamp
light appears here it goes out another
one appears over here that goes out then
and but the illusion As A View From a
Distance is if the objects have moved
back and forth and sometimes as gas will
gather into a ball and actually float
away
Allen made an ill-fated remark about
well some of these sightings could be
caused by swamp gas and the Witnesses
were upset to say the least
the people of Michigan thought that
heineck was making fun of them
that he thought they were all loonies
and Kooks and the whole thing blew up in
heinek's face they think you're a nut
tell you the truth that's just what they
figure you are and I'm not going to take
it anymore I don't want nobody down in
here I just leave me alone
when heinek came up with the swamp gas
explanation we don't really know whether
he believed that or not but we do know
that he was working for the Air Force
and they were committed at that point to
discrediting sightings like this one it
was a real turning point for the
beginning of people really uh just
having had enough of these kinds of
bogus explanations for these events
following the swamp gas incident the
public was outraged and even members of
Congress became involved
I had several incidents in Michigan that
many reliable citizens felt were
sufficient to justify some action by our
government and not the kind of flip and
answer that was given by the Air Force
where they passed it off as a swamp gas
Gerald Ford who was a congressman at the
time at Michigan decided that his
constituents were not being taken
seriously Gerald Ford listened to his
constituents and decided that he should
call for Congressional hearings I think
the American people would be more
assured that there were or were not in
such a public hearing was held
on April 5th 1966 Harold Brown the
secretary of the Air Force and J.L and
heinek walked into the Capitol Building
to answer questions about Blue Book's
investigation into UFOs we have not been
hiding anything the investigations have
been made public the explanations of
those where there is a clear explanation
have been made public they brought in
the secretary of the Air Force and he
just stonewalled and then came to be
heinek's turn to talk
he made his own statement that he hadn't
shared with anyone and he said look we
need to sponsor a scientific study and
tell us whether this is something we
need to keep studying how many really
mysterious incidents are there that
you'd like to go back and look at again
as I mentioned in the hearings this
morning I have picked some 20 cases I
think those I would recommend that
they'd be looked at quite closely
scientists has to keep open-minded on an
investigation
scientific one without Fanfare a quiet
look at the data I think is in order
heinek was initially a skeptic but as he
went through the years he gradually
learned that there really is something
to this
heinek started to believe that we could
learn a lot more about the phenomenon
through the better scientific study and
in fact that's what happened in
Stephenville Texas
good evening everyone my name is Steve
Hudgins I'm senior field investigator
for moofah we're down here to
investigate this extraordinary event we
have our kitchen director from Waco Dave
field
and director of research Robert Powell
my name is Robert Powell my educational
background is in chemistry and I work in
the semiconductor industry as an
engineering manager
early January of 2008 I'm the director
of research at mufant the term mufon
stands for Mutual UFO Network
I went up to Stephenville with multiple
investigators and we began to interview
the witnesses
hey how are you I'm good how are you I
met several key people such as Angela
Joyner Steve Allen and Leroy Gayton and
Leroy just gave me the best description
of what happened that day to him
as I walk out to my car I saw 10 to 12
bright fluorescent orbs they're moving
really quickly and then they stop and
then all of a sudden they shoot off
but what was surprising as I'm still
looking probably 20 30 seconds I hear
two jazz
are interviewing Leroy the first thing I
decided that I could do was get radar
data
Freedom of Information requests to the
FAA and I got that data back after about
six to eight weeks and it was incredible
[Music]
good morning my name is Robert Powell
I'm the director of research with the
move on organization we obtained radar
data from the Federal Aviation
Administration and the Stephenville area
I talk about this a little bit on the
screen here one of the first things I do
when I get the radar data is I find the
f-16s and I match that yes that matches
the time they went by Leroy's home then
I look on the radar data for unknowns
and I find two miles south of his home
just like he told me objects on radar
that are basically stationary just like
he said
and then the really interesting part was
on radar these objects that were over
his home the next radar blip the object
is to the Northeast towards Stephenville
and it had traveled at a minimum speed
of 1900 miles per hour now and that is
from stationaries
there's no way for me to know what it
was the only thing I can say is what it
was not it was not any type of aircraft
because no aircraft can hover and then
move to a speed of over 1900 miles an
hour at low altitude and then stop and
hover again it's just not something we
have the ability to do
[Music]
there are so many UFO sightings and the
vast majority of them can be explained
but then there are those that involve
Mass sightings of something really
unusual and in those cases people
deserve an investigation by the
officials in the aftermath of the swamp
gas case the government decided to fund
a college research program of the UFO
phenomenon
at the time the Air Force was trying to
find a way to get out from under the
burden of having to investigate UFOs and
comment on this and so a scientific
panel was established to investigate and
assess the issue it was led by a Dr
Robert Condon
what's his turn to the University of
Colorado to investigate unidentified
flying objects and they've asked Dr
Edward yukonden to head the project how
do you propose to go about studying this
particular phenomenon we'll pick certain
selected cases that seem especially
interesting and and go out and try to
learn more about them in those few in
Greater depth
the guy who was leading it Professor
Edward Condon had no interest in the
subject and had to be talked into it so
you have a professor who was not looking
to do a project that was given the
project and things didn't go well they
reviewed 59 cases and wrote them up in a
study that was close to a thousand pages
one of the events they covered was the
McMinnville incident in 1950 where the
farmer and his wife took a photograph of
a disc shaped object that came over
their Farm
the McMinnville photograph taken by a
poor rural couple in a remote area who
didn't seek any press and it showed a
UFO very clearly in in black and white
maybe 200 300 yards away
here's what the condom reports said
about the McMillan sighting
it's investigated geometric
psychological and physical appear to be
consistent with the assertion that an
extraordinary flying object flew within
sight of two witnesses and there were
other cases since they described in
similar ways
when the final report came out the main
body of the report was open to the
possibility that UFOs might be real
but the final summary of the report was
written by Dr Condon himself
Dr Conan sets time for the government to
just wash its hands of this whole thing
that's about the only thing most people
read
the Condon report concluded in 1969 this
was not a threat to National Security
there was no indication of
extraterrestrial connection and there
was likely no benefit scientifically
from continuing to study this phenomenon
foreign
Condon was somebody that was strenuously
opposed to the idea that UFOs could be
alien craft of any kind so from the
outset he had his mind made up
word is that Dr Condon himself didn't
even bother to read the the reporter
review the data he just wrote his
conclusion because that's what the Air
Force wanted to hear
Condon was definitely the nail in the
coffin for Project Blue Book the Air
Force had been involved with looking
into UFOs for more than 15 years they
were inundated by these reports
frustrated and just wanted to be done
with the whole thing
result was the Air Force said well we
don't need to follow this anymore so
they use that as a rationale to close
down Project Blue Book
shortly thereafter Dr Alan heineck
renounced the whole process and in the
way the Air Force handled it
some of us who followed this whole
phenomena became interested in the
Condon report what's your feeling about
that well my feeling is that the condron
report was a travesty on science you
don't feel like presenting a fair
picture Condon committee was unable to
explain one quarter of the cases that
were submitted that they studied
[Music]
our guest tonight is one of the world's
foremost authorities on unidentified
flying objects Dr J Allen heineck
[Music]
when Project Blue Book is shut down in
it freed heinek to say and do whatever
he wanted where UFOs were concerned
Dr heineck worked nearly two decades on
Project Blue Book and during that time
in the data that Project Blue Book had
collected the cases were still breaking
down in that very same 80 20 ratio he
was able to explain 80 percent of them
away he was not able to explain 20
percent of them and now he started to
worry about that he was a scientist and
he saw a trend and he thought that might
mean something
if these things didn't fit patterns and
then there's no way of studying it but
when you get reports from Australia
Japan France then you have to say well
either there's a virus going around
that's causing everybody to come crazy
at the same time or there's something to
it
heinek was finally free to start
investigating what UFOs are in any way
he wanted
so glad you're doing what you're doing
there aren't that many reporters that
take this seriously yeah I'm glad you're
doing it I've gotten tons of people you
know they walk up to me say thank you
for reporting it it's straight news and
then I think uh they just it was their
news judgment the publisher and the
editor that okay we don't want any more
of this let's get back to normal some
people said you were fired some people
said well you kind of wanted to leave
anyway so what was that given my notice
um they I was asked not to cover
anything else on UFOs I came in my
computer was gone my Rolodex was gone
and uh called to the Publisher's office
and uh it wasn't a pleasant scene and
they asked me to pack and go so I did
sadly when Angela left we never spoke
again
I hate that that story really divided us
but it did
she just
could not give back to doing her regular
reporting
it took over her life
[Music]
and I thought you know the readers are
going to like this they're going to
really like this so if that was another
reason I went ahead and did it and the
editor left early
I have never seen this that's hilarious
you know it's funny to see that
um
sorry I just I haven't seen Andrew in a
long time and she loved that story and
you know I look back on that time and I
think
I'm so wrong and I thought I was so
smart and I was so wrong
because they have the foresight to see
something that I couldn't and people did
love that story it was fun for them
I've never spoken about this but about a
year after this story died down I was
driving my daughter to gymnastics in one
evening
[Music]
it was Dusk and I saw
the exact same thing that everyone else
had been talking about the year prior a
big thing with the lights the clear
lights that kind of were all over the
place they went straight line and it
took off foreign
just remembering it
oh my God that's what we've been writing
about for a year and I was the biggest
skeptic of all and and here I am it was
a strange moment for sure
the next day I got to the office never
planned to say a word to anybody
and we had about a dozen calls that day
from others who said oh my gosh I think
I saw that again
[Music]
went
okay there there really was something to
this but it took me that long
the government should be looking at this
of course I have to believe that what
happened in Stephenville County was big
enough that it got the attention of the
government I just believe that and I
believe they know a heck of a lot more
than than we do
please welcome from the center of UFO
studies in Evanston Illinois Dr J Allen
heineck Dr heineck
in the years that followed J.L and
heineck became a hero advocating for the
study of UFOs Dr heineck realized that
this was a serious problem these things
are coming over our bases over our
nuclear facilities I thought we were
under attack by who or what I had no
idea
[Music]
thank you